joining us with more Fox News
contributor former White House press
secretary Sarah Sanders and Fox News
contributor Katie Pavlich Katie the
thing would be god our creator of
everything that's the thing he forgot
about the thing you know it's John this
reminds me of when Hillary Clinton had
that medical situation when she
collapsed on 9/11 in New York City we
were all supposed to just ignore it as
if it wasn't some kind of big concern
for the biggest job in the world
you know Joe Biden has clearly made some
Mis statements on the campaign trail
just two weeks ago on Fox News Sunday he
had a lengthy interview with Chris
Wallace and at the end of the interview
called him Chuck and then said that he
doesn't understand how people do early
mornings so there are serious questions
about his ability to keep up on the
campaign trail I think President Trump
is probably pretty happy about this
looking like it's going to be his
eventual opponent because President
Trump has been campaigning for over a
year now he loves doing it he has a lot
of energy and he's efficient when it
comes to getting to running the White
House at the same time as being able to
go out and campaign for re-election you
know Sarah will say I may surprise
people
bolshevik Bernie he doesn't seem like he
just had a heart attack and by the way I
don't even with all the modern medicine
treatment technology stenting bypass
everything in between a guy he's got a
lot of Bolshevik energy in there he does
not seem to be struggling on the
campaign trail and he's a year older
then quid pro quo certainly has the
energy but not the ideas but one of the
things I feel like is lost anybody that
has been watching Joe Biden on the
campaign trail or the debate stage knows
he's a terrible candidate but let's not
forget that anybody who's also paying
attention knows that his extremely
liberal policy ideas would make him an
even worse president he's a bad
candidate he would be even worse as
president of this country he is
supporting taxpayer-funded abortion free
health care for illegals the green New
Deal which would be disastrous for the
American economy and American jobs he is
not a moderate that they're claiming to
be his policy positions are liberal
he would be a terrible president for so
many reasons
just like Bernie Sanders would be
terrible and I think the president
whether it's Bernie or Biden he's in
good shape
going up against either one of these two
guys look at their position on okay
health care Katie for illegal immigrants
open borders there's their radical
position on the Second Amendment the
radical position is on guns and Oh green
new deal less oil and gas the lifeblood
of our economy the first time in 75
years where energy independent will go
back on that what we're going to go back
to bribing mullahs in Iran we're going
to go back to what 13 million more
Americans on food stamps 8 million
worn-in on in poverty and the lowest
labor participation rates into the 70s
we're going to go back to that he's got
a record and barrese but by the way Kati
is not going away either
no it certainly is not going away that
can of worms hasn't even been completely
opened yet yeah Joe Biden has admitted
that he wants to raise taxes he wants to
repeal the Trump tax cuts which were
good for the vast majority of Americans
especially in the middle class in this
country he's put bado a Rourke in charge
or a beta or can charge of gun control
policy which that means gun confiscation
which is completely unconstitutional and
if everybody believes in the democratic
party that somehow Joe Biden is going to
swing the party back to the middle from
the left they're completely against what
the reality of the situation is in that
party Joe Biden is going to get eaten
alive by the left wing of the party the
AOC is Ilhan Omar's
Nancy Pelosi couldn't even handle
keeping them together in the house which
led down this road of impeachment of
President Trump not to mention Joe Biden
who can't even stand up to these ideas
and put forward his own platform when it
comes to being out on the campaign trail
in a real moderate way his policies are
very far left and yet were stuck with
this talking point that he's somehow the
normal one who everybody should be
voting for and look at it Sarah Sanders
you've been around President Trump I've
been around President Trump he's got the
energy of leg 10 40 year-olds you know
he has more I'm under 40 I'm proud to
say and Donald Trump had
more energy than me every single day
that I worked for by the way I was doing
it most embarrassing how many circles he
ran around the rest of us he goes I'd go
home on this trip I was talking to him
he was leaving Vietnam and I just had an
interview with him yeah and everybody's
gonna be sleeping I'm the only one
that's gonna stay up because they're all
laid out in the Air Force one true story
all right thank you both